dr jesus jarrah is back on the clock as
superintendent of the clark county
school district and one of the first
items of business discussing the
employee covet 19 vaccine mandate thank
you for joining us at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm christian casadas
employee union say discussions have
started again after being on hold for
several weeks it's now been three months
since the school board
granted superintendent dr jesus the
ability to develop the mandate kate
houston is live from a kid's coven 19
vaccine clinic at rafaela rivera
community center near stewart and mohave
with the latest developments kate
yes here kids 5 to 17 can get the pfizer
covid 19 vaccine and the teachers union
tells me they're actually only in the
preliminary talks at this time with the
school district on the employee vaccine
mandate but now that school age kids
like the ones here can get their shots
the union says there should be a
discussion on whether students are
factored into a potential mandate
and we're prepared to go back to the
table with them today if they're ready
to do so the clark county education
association hoping the district is ready
to get back on track all that stuff got
on hold in large part because of what
we've seen play out again it's the
political chicanery of this school board
executive director john valardita says
the vaccine mandate is complex and not a
black and white issue we'd hate to see
a policy that forces
educators to make career decisions at a
time when there's over 800 vacancies the
vaccine mandate would impact more than
40 thousand employees but with 305
thousand students back in class
valardita says discussions shouldn't
focus solely on workers but students too
i think it's incumbent of leadership to
take that issue on
it's going to clearly affect what we sit
down and negotiate at the table all
right so we're not telling them one way
or the other in terms of what to do but
what we're saying is lead the clark
county association of school
administrators says they received an
email from ccsd asking to meet and to
see where they stand on the employee
vaccine mandate a meeting has not yet
been set
back out live when the district and
employee unions come to an agreement it
would go back before the school board
board president linda cavazos tells me
that she has not received any updates on
that yet i have reached out to ccsd for
some more information on the vaccine
mandate i have not yet heard back
reporting live near stewart and mohave
kate houston live local now